[Music]
you know I can't believe we're back
we're gonna be back I mean it's right
we're gonna be back
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Rick and Morty season
4 trailer video for the back half of the
season they released a new mr. poopy
butthole promo to fill in the gap
between the first half of season 4 and
the second half so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos I will keep doing
bonus videos for the series while we
wait for episodes to come back and we
are still doing that merch giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the season on the video so
as they've done in the past they use
this character to sort of tag the end of
a block of episodes in between seasons
even though technically it's the back
half of season 4 it's not like we're
going from season 4 episode 5 to season
5 they'll be episodes 6 through 10 next
year but starting with season 3 they
started to get really crazy and meta
with it releasing these kinds of
trailers to fill in the gaps in his
timeline between seasons where isn't a
traditional series you would actually
expect to get this backstory through
some exposition in an actual episode
like his season 4 episode 3 he just
shows up as a professor teaching a
lecture course so either he's an
alternate version or he just got his PhD
really fast after he got his GED as he
calls it in that season 3 post credits
scene this one is really just for the
Christmas holiday this week but it's mr.
poopy butthole going on vacation with
his wife and son at a cabin in Rick
portaling and to check on him and then
leave the cabin is supposed to be a
reference to the same cabin that Rick's
family went to hide out at in the
wilderness when trying to get away from
Rick at the end of season 3 that was
really just because they were afraid
that he was gonna get rid of Beth
because she still wasn't a hundred
percent on whether or not she was a
clone I know there's still a lot of
theories out there about that even Dan
Harmon still likes to tease people about
that that's a clown just to be clear
that's not him confirming that Beth is a
clone that just him having a little bit
of fun with the people that are filming
this interview that they had at Comic
Con but the other clip is him just
looking at his scrapbook filling in the
gaps in his timeline between the season
2 post credits scene in the season 3
post credits scene like where did his
kid come from how did he meet his wife
what's going on here so they give you
all this extra backstory showing him at
all these different locations during the
season three episodes through his
timeline as he slowly meets his wife
like you flash back to him when he was
Morty's age in a class where he met his
version of Jessica it's even like a mrs.
poopy butthole design
to look kind of like a Jessica then
they're a little bit older still
studying in school but they're sitting
on a bench from Cronenberg world made up
of a whole bunch of different people
just going back to that planet then they
graduate high school they get their GEDs
like he said in the season three
post-credits scene just as it looks like
the Galactic government is taking over
their world at the end of season two
then they're just a little bit older
they have the same rebellion arc in the
background as you see season 3 episode 1
the Galactic government leaving earth
then they visit the same detoxification
spa from season 3 episode 6 and it seems
like they had the same fight with their
toxic selves make all the theories you
want about what parts of mr. poopy
butthole you think for toxic probably
the part that took all those pills
because when he comes back he's not on
the pills anymore this is them during
the events of season 3 episode 3 you see
Jaguar in the background getting ready
to jump out of a plane then they're a
little bit older they're continuing
their courtship with a picnic in the
park while they're being watched from
the bushes by one of the aliens from
season 3 episode 9 that Jerry was
hunting with Chiara then there's a
version of his proposal that matches
exactly Morty's memory-foam Morty's mind
blowers that Rick had to erase I saw a
lot of people after that split on what
Morty's memory of this meant a lot of
people thought that he was just helping
him practice his proposal the other half
thought that it really did mean he was
proposing to Morty who then said yes and
had to have his memory wiped
because it would be complete disaster
for Rick and he didn't want to have any
part of that nonsense they get married
they revealed that he's canonically
Jewess she's being married by the rabbi
that you see pop up in regular Rick and
Morty episodes or his wife was and he
converted to her religion then it seems
like him moving them into a different
apartment within the complex of
apartments that he lives in because the
apartment is almost the exact same but
there was no dining room in the season
two apartment he was living in then
there's this whole montage of him
scrapbooking his pets like their people
in this relationship that runs its own
full arc from friendship to to the death
of the cat there's even a plum bus here
in the background
everyone is so sad that the cat is dying
he can't help it but wait within what
looks like minutes of him grieving his
wife is telling him she's pregnant with
their son looking at the ultrasound here
I guess we learned Easter egg that the
poopy butthole species grow their top
hats in the womb so it's part of their
body if you're super big Nintendo fan
that sort of like the Joe
about toads head what's going on is he
wearing a hat is that mushroom sitting
on his head or is that actually part of
his head and if you weren't sure that
actually is part of his head that is not
a hat that he wears you kind of have to
assume that his species or the culture
behind his race is toilet based so the
poopy butthole name has some logic in
there reality this is just meant to be
the baby shower this is her doing that
Beyonce posed from that post a couple
years ago if you don't remember she got
pregnant with her first child with jay-z
they did this whole big baby reveal
thing because the birth of their son
then he looks up at the sky thinking a
higher power for his good fortune just
because he was in such a terrible place
after season two addicted to all those
pills there been a lot of people that
have wondered if his character is just
going around on adventures with an
alternate version of Rick that's not
c-137 Rick and that's how they explained
the way they use him in episodes making
you wonder if he's real or not real is
this all happening is this imaginary he
is a confirmed real character but the
way the writers were using him when he
showed up during season two was to
Gaslight you the audience because the
whole episode was about gas lighting
like wait a minute what's real what's
fake what's just these parasites making
me think that all this stuff happened
showing you he's real at the end of the
episode but for some strange reason Beth
doesn't have any pictures of him even
though he's been hanging out with their
family this whole time so the easiest
way to explain that is that he's just
going around with an alternate version
of Rick that's not c-137 Rick you could
also just chalk that up to Beth being
kind of an and not thinking
about mr. poopy butthole because if
she's not gonna put jerry's number in
her phone and they're married then why
would she have pictures of a bunch of
other people hi you went directly to
voicemail because your number is not in
my phone don't leave a message but
everyone let me know if you spotted any
big easter eggs and these holiday promos
that I didn't mention in the video and
I'll keep doing bonus videos as they
release more promos for the back half of
season 4 or if we get any big news about
when episodes are actually coming back
congratulations Matthew Williams you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Rick & Morty video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details everyone click here for
my season 4 episode 5 video and click
here for my Rick and Morty season 4
episode 6 trailer video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
Happy Holidays
[Music]